[Musique]
angers caen aventure les appels
encore chers auditeurs tu écoutes le
dernier épisode de cette saison de
l'épopée temporaire eli roth s'est
sacrifié la bus a tué tous les
dinosaures
sauf un et le petit lapin accompagne
iris et thomas dans le laboratoire du
docteur simon pour arrêter une bonne foi
et ris numéro 2 de casser le temps
j'espère que ça va bien se terminer
[Musique]
ça me rassure tellement de voir que mon
époque existe toujours imagine que mes
cinq étoiles
il ne faut pas que tu fais un cauchemar
c'est normal c'est une histoire où le
relief
ça doit être la méchante iris putelat
qu'il approchait à une simulation dès
maintenant
il pourrait mourir il faut d'abord le
prévenir qu'il est dans une simulation
sinon il va faire un arrêt cardiaque on
veut dire qu'on doit entrer dans la
simulation oui mais d'abord il faut
jolie trouve dans ce monde virtuel ou
escalade tir pull m tourne en boucle
dans son propre passé
ses écrits cauchemar infinie la branche
et on perd dans un cauchemar un fini mon
père c'est aussi son père si je voulais
le punir dans quel cauchemar un finish
pour elle coince et moi ce serait le
moment on a supprimé ma sauvegarde
pokémon rouge et sans thomas oui un
événement qui l'a traumatisée et un
baudracco venu mosson je sais que ma
propre câble et mélo dans ton oreille
d'accord on va le rejoindre dans son
pire souvenir le jour où ma mère l'a
quitté non dans ton oreille
thomas roth
[Musique]
donc là on est dans l'ordinateur
c'est super sobeys mme estrela l'air
tellement plus jeunes la foire à côté il
ya une chose acquise
[Musique]
chose incroyable mais pourquoi je ne
trouve jamais deux chaussettes
semblables c'est faux mais si on n'était
pas aussi heureux tous les deux c'est le
genre de phrase qui pourrait me faire
peur à pérouse je te quitte quoi mais
pourquoi il ya quelqu'un d'autre
oui mais ce n'est pas la question je ne
suis pas heureuse avec toi tu n'as
aucune ambition tu ne vas jamais au bout
de rien quand je t'ai rencontrée tu
étais scientifique génial mais enfin mon
amour je dois je suis toujours à
scientifique génial tu n'es jamais rien
d'inventé tu as des idées en l'air et tu
abandonnes non je n'abandonne pas
c'est juste que je préfère passer tout
mon temps de libre avec toi plutôt que
dans mon impôt de plus mais pourquoi tu
pars avec public donne des ego ou crise
car l'idée mais non
une autre enfant puis à penser
je te préviens tu ne m'enlèvera part
pour toujours si moi je te la série
visant non ne pas tout mon coeur se
brise en mille morceaux
je suis seul comme une chaussette
chaussettes grise ou l'autre chaussettes
toi tu n'aurais pas d'une chaussette
crise à moi j'ai qu'une chose cette
crise et c'est horrible sa mère avait
abandonné un seul n'a jamais on va
prévenir ton père non je t'attends c'est
le passage on pleure pour toujours gémir
je te laisse oublie pas qu il attend
vers disparaît la romanité parce qu'il
avait la flemme de s'excuser open moi
c'est bon là mais c'est pourquoi pas
kefu que fit vous chez moi c'est moi
iris est celle de souvenirs iris
c'est pas possible tu un tout petit bébé
faut que je te dis non c'est pas la
vraie maman mais mais regarde regarde je
passe mon bras à travers l eau
trop bizarre comment vous faites ça vous
fait ça fait ça je ne suis pas heureuse
je te quitte tu vois elle est programmée
pour dire ça à partir dans tes souvenirs
c'est une simulation une simulation
thomas tué thomas c'est bien ça oui oui
tu es le petit ami dirigeants nous
non non j'ai non attention c'est fini ça
vous n'êtes plus ensemble eh ben je suis
soulagé oui bon pas la peine de fêter ça
non allez on sort de la simulation
c'était horrible âge je me sens si
déprimée vous avez réveillé mon père
hérisson mousse vous avez fait échouer
les plans étaient très calmes et 29
je vais faire ce que je devais faire
depuis le début vous transpercer la tête
avec mon désintégrateur frottant
la révolution c'est tu sais que je
t'aime
comment tu le sais quoi du colis
pourquoi sourit bêtement alors qu'elle
va mourir que je m'étais caché ce
sentiment trop longtemps et je peux
mourir sa reine
je suis en thème en paix mais oui oui
oui c'est ça que je veux moi mais
pourquoi j'ai pas ça moi là je crois que
c'est encore ma faute
et oui dans la simulation j'ai tout fait
pour te garder pour moi je ne voulais
pas que tu aimes quelqu'un d'autre que
moi c'est donc ça le vide en moi des
eaux
ça me ronge et me donne de la colère il
me manque l'amour je me sens pour la
prochaine simulation
moi aussi je veux être comme une loterie
risque je vais être heureuse et
amoureuse toi l'avortement
je je je t'aime j'hallucine
tu veux voler mon thomas aimons nous je
te donne est ce que tu veux je suis
capable de faire de grandes chances
tu sais oui ça c'est sûr comme détruire
l'humanité je changerai pour toi tout
bas je serai ça que tu veux donc on
s'aime et je te respecterait plus que
l'autre irisé où je respecte thomas
vraiment j'ai l'impression que tu as
passé ton temps à plaindre de moi mais
aimer non non c'était avant statut voix
c'est pas la bonne pour toi moi je
t'aime tu crois c'est une blague ou quoi
tu peux pas choisir un algorithme
mauboussin tendances psychopathes qui
complètement stupide vous l'a déjà dit
plein de fois et aussi gros débile
immature inutile mais c'est ça m'a
blessé je suis désolé thomas avoir passé
du temps à tes côtés
ça m'a ouvert les yeux
j'ai plus de sentiments pour toi comme
mais n'est trop différent mais non iris
j'ai besoin de quelqu'un d'autre
maman thomas jamais je ne manquerais de
respect je t'aime comblement vide choisi
points d'accord possibles par c'est
maintenant on fait quoi quand on est
amoureux
je vois s'embrasser à pruszkow oui on
devra s'en tenant ferme les yeux
thomas mon amour elle est branchée à la
simulation fermer les sur iton la
production chez câble thomas toute façon
il ya d'ailleurs je veux qu'on perd son
nom je dirais un peu
voilà j'ai coupé le son bon je crois que
c'est fini
bien joué et thomas regarder le temps
est réparé iris 2 est partie tout comme
les paradoxes temporels
même si j'avoue que c'est un poil
déceptif j'imaginais qu'on allait vivre
nos bagarres épiques avec un méchant
dictateur pour finir cette mission par
une discussion autour de l'amour est un
petit coup de tu veux de bagarre je
suis allé voler l'exosquelette motorisée
de votre copain pirates pour venir vous
pouvez terrain mais pourquoi tu nous ont
pour elles réfléchissent à cause des
c'est la première fois qu'on s'est vus
on calculait pas je ne manque pas grand
chose juste au sol plus tard des toiles
5 étoiles vous croyez que ma bulle n'est
facile qui avait pas des petites
bouteilles d'eau pendant voyage s'il n'y
avait pas des bonbons à la menthe alors
pourquoi nous traiter comme ça on non
mais c'était un super service même faut
pas t'énerver pour ça j'ai essayé de
mettre cinq étoiles j'ai essayé plein de
fois l'application d'un buggy battant
j'ai réessayé tout de suite regarde
petit lapin sur mon petit lapin
si vous
mais vraiment utiliser l'application
vous avez vu mon prénom alors comment je
m'appelle a nommé calme-toi neveu de
françois n'ont jamais tissu élimination
pourquoi ça marche pas on a reparlé papa
tu attrapes l'un de l'autre et risma
partira pas
à petit la par les parties super il a
laissé l'armée yacht c'est bien toi
qu'on a entendu oui le jeu suit dans
leurs murs cette étrange j'ai beau avoir
été exposées effacé puis démontée
j'existe encore attendez je vais
analyser le programme de l'armure la
puce il y haute c'est toi qui écris ces
lignes de code intitulé liberté
non je regarde dans l'historique du code
et 29 ans ckb 29 qui a écrit un
programme pour te réanimer en fonction
de certaines variables ne peut pas pas
quoi les variables sont les émotions oui
je les ressens mais c'est impossible je
ressens de la joie de la vie tier pour
vous de l'amour
elle a dû injecter ce code moment de
l'explosion quoi c'est signé de la part
de k b 29 pour elliott kim enseigner
comment devenir un être libre c'est fou
je vais remettre ses versions des
lionnes dans une nouvelle machine tu
pleures ça m'a fait de la peine quand tu
as choisi le trévise mais maintenant je
suis soulagé tout est rentré dans
l'ordre on va pouvoir procéder et ris je
pense et ce que je disais
comment ça j'ai plus de sentiments pour
tous les goûts va avoir un enfant non
ton père a dit que le temps a changé nos
actes peuvent influencer l'avenir on est
maîtres de notre destinée
non thomas merci pour toutes ces
aventures j'ai appris beaucoup sur qui
j'étais cette machine part pas il est
temps que je rentre chez moi
[Musique]
maman tu es là un mois quoi moi viens
avec moi il faut que tu me suis quoi j'y
crois pas thomas est parti mais il
devait finir avec iris
enfin c'est pas possible autrement et
c'est qui cette jeune fille qui prend un
risque pour sa mère quand je suis
bouleversée jugé plus l'âge pourtant
d'émotion gilles 26 ans pour ceux qui se
posent la question
avant de se quitter chers auditeurs je
propose qu'on jette un coup d'oreille
dans la simulation
cette montre les sciences
dans les siens ne sommes bien sûr son
nom
message bolt est quelque chose on n'a
pas trop c
comment savez vous pouvez dans une
simulation oui je les fais opus eurois
monture
s'envole vers le seul endroit on sera en
sécurité les états unis de la corée du
nord kim jong strap mr avec rêve merci
pour ce travail ou la liberté
du coup peut-être la boue un sincère
merci à toi chers auditeurs d'avoir
écouté cette nouvelle saison de l'épopée
temporel j'espère que l'aventuré a plu
comme elle m'a plu à imaginer et
fabriquer merci à toute l'équipe
technique
les comédiens les auteurs le compositeur
les illustrateurs et tous ceux qui ont
participé à ce projet et je réserve une
surprise aux fans de la série
une surprise collector je vous dis à
très vite sur internet
[Musique]